[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERDEM INAN: Peak Games
was founded in 2010.
Our aim is to create
global technology products
and reach millions of users.
We're based in Istanbul, so
we started targeting Turkey.
But very quickly, we expanded
into other countries.
We take the classic game
experience and migrate it
to mobile, creating a
very socially dynamic,
interactive, community-driven
game so that people can
socialize, have a fun time,
send each other gifts,
chat in a digital environment.
Additional to that, we
also build casual games--
the level-based tapping,
swiping, matching type
of games.
Our aim is to scale
up all of our games,
specifically in
their target markets,
and be a reputable
player globally.
Android is our priority
mobile platform.
Currently, we have 65k
of installs every day
from Android.
For Spades Plus, for example,
we have more than 70%
of our mobile revenue coming
from the Android platform.
Most of our games are
dependent on scale.
They get more fun when
we have people chatting,
gifting each other.
And getting more
users in Android
is a lot easier than any
other mobile platform.
Its dynamic structure, its
flexible, fast iteration cycles
allow us to quickly
fix something
if something is not going well.
This gives us a
lot of flexibility,
because most of
our classic games
depend heavily on
user experience.
ILKIN ULAS BALKANAY:
Google Play staged
rollout helps us fix critical
marks before the game is
downloaded by
millions of players.
After adding new
features to our games,
we release the update
to 5% of our users.
Then we monitor
the user feedback.
And if everything is OK,
we increase the percentage,
and make the game visible
to all of our players.
ERDEM INAN: We've seen
that the app store
images can change the conversion
of an app up to 20-30%.
And we've also seen that short
description, long description,
all have an effect
on your conversion.
And even a 5% increase
in our conversion
corresponds greatly to
our cost per installs,
to our marketing
ROI, and eventually
to the size of the game.
Android has been super
helpful in growing
in the international markets.
We've seen that the user
acquisition was easier,
and it's massive in scale.
There a lot of
companies that you
can work with in terms
of user acquisition.
Average cost per
acquisition in Android
has been around
30-40% lower than
the other mobile platforms.
And adverts is our strongest
source of acquisitions.
It's connected to all
other Google products.
That allows us a
greater visibility
on how we're performing.
These type of things create
a long-lasting business
for Peak Games.
And for the last
three years, we're
mostly focusing on Western
Europe and North America,
and trying to grow our games
in international markets,
because that's where we
believe our future is lying in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]